Усі труднощі долати разом.
Це чи не єдине, що не змінилося в житті
кримськотатарської родини Рамазанових.
Три роки тому Руслан та Сефає виїхали з Кримучерез анексію.
У Сімферополі залишилися будинок та бізнес -
власний стоматологічний кабінет.
Поновити бізнес у Львові було дуже складно.
Адже, за законом, кримчани мають статус
нерезидентів України і правила ведення бізнесу для них інші.
Кримчани не можуть тут
у Львові, за місцем зареєструватися як ФОП.
Нам потрібно було відправляти документи в Енергодар
в Запорізькій області.
Така тяганина тривала місяці.
Заощаджували на собі, на дітях, мали лише державні виплати переселенця,
а це приблизно 800 гривень на людину.
До того ж, винаймали житло,
а це також чималі кошти. Утім, подружжя не здалося.
Закінчили бізнес-курси у Львові.
39-річний Руслан отримав додаткову
медичну спеціалізацію.
Спершу орендували кабінет. А незабаром придбали
й обладнання – частково на гранти
міжнародних фондів, а частково на позичені гроші.
У нас були серйозні проблеми.
По-перше, доводилося ризикувати,
оскільки оренда дуже висока.
Все це треба було узгоджувати документально.
І все це - набагато складніше, ніж, приміром, відкрити магазин або щось подібне.
Адже у нас специфічна галузь.
Утім, і в сфері обслуговування почати все з нуля
для переселенців з Криму теж далеко непросто.
Руслан Аблямітов із Сімферополя переїхав до
Львова теж одразу після псевдореферендуму.
За фахом він менеджер. У Криму працював
у закладах громадського харчування.
Тому й ризикнуввідкритикафе.
І зміг втриматися на специфічному львівському ринку.
Те, що я особисто спостерігав за останні три роки,
справді через те, що економічна ситуація
в Україні нестабільна,
і важко прижитися в новому місті, орендуючи житло,
хлопці з родинами, які приїхали сюди,
вимушені були повернутися в Крим
або переїхати в інші, більш дешеві регіони, приміром, у Херсон.
Наші співрозмовники - радше винятки,
які підтверджують правило.
За оцінками, з майже двох тисяч кримських татар,
які в 2014 виїхали до Західної України,
щонайменше третина згодом залишили Львівщину.
Чоловіки просто не змогли знайти гідної роботи,
щоб годувати свої родини та платити за оренду квартир.
Пільгового житла для переселенців держава не пропонує.
Як і підтримки з працевлаштування і
впорядкування документів кримчан.